but first let's talk to the just justice
secretary and deputy prime minister
dominic grab good morning deputy prime
minister good morning um
i'd like to start with the murder of
arthur le benjo hughes um
can you confirm that there will be an
inquiry into this murder
yes good morning trevor look uh as a
father of young boys myself as a parent
alone as justice secretary i can't begin
to imagine how anyone could be that
cruel
let me tell you exactly what we're doing
we've had those sentences for the two
parents the attorney general's made
clear she wants to rev have them
reviewed where we have a mechanism for
doing so there'll be a local
safeguarding review which will look at
the local authorities actions whether
any lessons could have been picked up
earlier whether any warning flags could
have been put up earlier and the prime
minister's made clear as well as that we
want to see how social services and the
local authorities liaised with the
criminal justice agencies and what
lessons further we can learn this is the
second case i've dealt with this week i
saw tony hudgell and his parents paul
and mark another very very sad case of
child cruelty we've immediately and i
announced steps to increase the
sentences the most vulnerable in our
society need to have the maximum
protection
well as you said this is not the first
time we can go back through the roll
call
kaylee jade
priest peter connolly victoria clambier
there's a list of horror that goes back
more than uh two decades and we already
know part of the problem don't we
not enough social workers and perhaps
not enough good training for those
social workers it's right to review it's
right to inquiry but couldn't we get on
with doing something about that because
we know already that's part of the
problem well there's a multi-uh
dimensions to this uh there's uh the the
fact that
the individuals responsible for any of
this cruelty uh could be so callous
there is also the local authority
response and i would say that i think
the social workers on the front line do
an incredible job as part of the
pandemic response we've invested close
to five billion pounds in giving local
authorities the support they need
because one of the things we know about
lockdown whilst lots of families enjoyed
a bit more time together for those that
are the victims of domestic abuse it has
been a very serious time some of those
risks have been magnified
and we're taking the action we also need
to take as i announced with the
announcement this week of tony's law
tougher sentences for those who would
commit this unimaginable cruelty on
children but isn't this rather like
the uh victoria columbia case where the
inquiry by lord lehming
way back in the early 2000s
spotted i think it was 17 different
occasions where the social services
could have intervened but didn't for a
variety of reasons
and this case
arthur le binjo hughes echoes that
precisely isn't that
really where we ought to be focusing our
attention right now look i think it's
part of the picture i think there's a
silver bullet answer to this i mean
you've got to ask how anyone could
commit this kind of unimaginable cruelty
um why we've got families that might
countenance let alone commit such abuse
it's right that we look at the criminal
justice end and in between that i think
the job of social workers particularly
those looking at children of uh at
particular risk we need to learn the
lessons of course it's very difficult
for social workers on the front line
especially if there aren't enough of
them yes but this is often reduced to
the question of resources i've just
explained that during the pandemic we've
put in i think was 4.8 billion close to
5 billion pounds but they do an
incredibly difficult job it's very
finely balanced on the one hand they
need to
make sure they've got the engagement the
relationship that those families talk to
them on the other hand of course the top
priority has got to be looking for those
risks reading the signs which may only
be subtle
and in with the benefit of hindsight be
more obvious but at the time
i do think though we've got to make sure
if you like a more precautionary
approach which looks at the the risk to
those particularly vulnerable young
children and see what more we can do to
read those signs earlier and better all
right let's discuss the precautionary
principle on a larger scale we're
talking now about covid
um
last night we got a new travel ban
um
actually you could have applied the
precautionary principle a week ago
shouldn't you it's too late well in
relation to the omicron variant we
actually acted quicker than i think any
other country in the world perhaps with
the exception of israel
in putting uh
travel restrictions on people coming
from countries particularly
in africa in relation to the pcr tests
for people coming into this country look
we i know that that's a burden for the
travel industry but we've made huge huge
strides in this country we've got uh 80
percent of those over 12 double jab now
we've got a third of the country uh with
a third jab or a booster we've got to
take the measures targeted forensically
to stop the new variant seeding in this
country to create a bigger problem we're
going into this christmas in a far far
better stage
state we can enjoy christmas this year
in a way that we couldn't last year that
is a testament to the vaccine program in
particular the boosters which are
protecting us uh through this winter the
colder months with also the risks from
the variants so actually i think we have
done the right thing we've taken a
balanced approach but we always alert to
extra risks that take us back not
forward your number one priority is
still to protect the nhs um there's some
data emerging this morning which says
that 90 percent
uh of those uh in hospital in coveted
beds are
unvaccinated
and that takes up 20 of critical care
beds and
wouldn't it make sense uh if you want to
protect the nhs to do something about
that other countries are now moving
towards mandatory vaccination um
shouldn't we be making sure that people
who
basically are endangering others uh
suffer some consequences before they
take up that 90
uh of beds well look first of all can i
say that
again if you look at the data yes
there's been some extra transmission of
the virus because of omicron but
actually if you compare the data this
week compared to last week and we look
at this very carefully hospitalizations
are down deaths uh as a result of
covered down in relation to occupancy in
nhs and the beds that you described
which is pre-omicron yes of course look
we are
absolutely clear people should get the
jab they should get double jab they
should get the booster when it's
available and i'm i'm not convinced that
wholesale straightjacket mandatory
vaccinations other than in those
settings where it's really required like
social care and for staff working in the
nhs in in hospitals i'm not i'm not
convinced that that would be effective
and whether it's fair and right and uh
morally the right thing to do i'm not
we've got to make sure that those who
are vaccine uh hesitant if you like got
the confidence to do it and anyone that
is reading the data reading the
efficacy of what the vaccines can
achieve including against omicron with
the latest research that we have
published on friday this must be the
right thing to do so i set the premise
of your question which is anyone that
isn't having the vaccine is putting
themselves but also uh other people in
our community at risk i'm just not
lengthening that six million
person waiting list well then you've got
to ask me that question i i'm i i'm not
convinced it will be an effective thing
to do to say everyone has got to
compulsory uh have the vaccine what we
want to do is say get it done it's the
right thing to do you should have the
vaccine it's irresponsible not to have
the vaccine that's the approach we're
taking all right look on omicron um
to put it at its most blunt uh
not that many people have died compared
to what we've seen with delta
um there is a case for saying that what
you're doing is a bit of an overreaction
we always get the goldilocks criticism
of too much too little and i think we've
taken the right approach we're focused
on the vaccines the boosters we've got a
third of the population over 12 with a
third
vaccine
injection or with a booster
but we are taking the measures and we've
seen that with travel and i know some
people will feel uh overburdened by that
to say look we are going to prevent uh
the variance omicron and others coming
in uh and what's called reseeding uh in
the uk because we
we've got to make sure that we bank the
progress that we've made go into
christmas have a great christmas and go
into the new year uh bouncing back we've
got the economy uh
expanding jobs are up wages are up we've
got to as well as make sure we protect
everyone's health and lives and safety
also make sure we protect livelihoods i
think we've taken a balanced approach i
was hoping you wouldn't bring up
christmas but you have so let me just
ask you that the are you hoping that
wouldn't bring up christmas because i
have because
i know i have to ask you the tabloid
questions okay in the christmas season
yeah some ministers are telling us that
we can have parties some are telling us
that we can't do what's natural under
the mistletoe now i see that um the
conservative party chairman um oliver
dowden uh is going ahead with the uh
party headquarters um
christmas party uh have you um
sorted out the ministry of justice
christian party you can have one i take
it well first of all the rule is very
clear people can go in and have
christmas parties of course employers
will want to think common sense about
how they do that we we we don't want to
um uh substitute for the for that
discretion and that common sense i we
won't be having a ministry of justice
wide
christmas party this year um but uh
we'll be having i think appropriate uh
drinks at a smaller scale what does an
appropriate drink look like in this
context and i'm not you may want to
reflect on what happened last year but
what what does an appropriate and this
is quite a serious point actually
because lots of us are being asked
to get to join our colleagues what is
right and what is wrong here what's
advised well so the right thing to do is
for every employer to take a common
sense view we want let me be absolutely
clear government wants people to be able
to enjoy christmas this year that means
people should feel uh free to go and
enjoy those uh celebrations and every
employer will think about the right way
to do it
and and i'm the same as anyone else so
you're not really offering any guidance
now we are we're saying with the
guidance we're offering is we say first
of all you can have those christmas
events second of all we want to allow
the common sense discretion of employers
to make the right call all right let's
move on to your own particular area you
are um signaling today and i think this
week that you're going to um get tough
on county lines you're really trying to
make some progress on some issues of
crime let's just start if i may with the
incredibly important issue
of
rape
and you're preparing to offer greater
rights of people who suffered
um
though that particular crime
what are you actually proposing on rape
so we'll settle out some proposals later
on this week but first of all we're
going to be publishing scorecards both
for general crime but also for rape
which means we can see exactly where the
system is working and exactly
where it isn't working whether it's at
the police stage the prosecution stage
prosecution's getting to court i'm
hosting a tech summit tomorrow one of
the things that we're looking at in
relation to the rape review and we're
going to be publishing our six monthly
update on where we've got to that was
an action plan announced in june we're
going to be showing how we've made
progress one of the things we're looking
at is how tech can drive up prosecutions
whether it's the
ability to get swifter
readouts from mobile phones from victims
that come forward so they're not
deprived of their mobile phone for long
we know that that's something that
undermines confidence in coming forward
to the police one of the particular
things that i've been looking at is
what's called section 28 pre-recorded
testimony for the victims of rape we've
been trying this in the uh in a number
of crown courts i actually think this is
something we need to roll out nationally
i want to look at the right way to do
that the advantage that it has for a
victim is that they have the opportunity
to give their evidence without being
through the additional trauma of the
glare of the courtroom and that can
secure more prosecutions but it also can
encourage early guilty pleas i think
it's the right thing to do but it's also
an effective way of driving up those
prosecutions the tech will help but and
i know you won't particularly like to
get on to this territory but let's be
clear the cps crown prosecution service
say
that the appallingly low level of rape
convictions is in part due to the fact
they don't have enough people the cops
say that uh the
their inability to gather evidence and
bring forward successful cases is also
down to a lack of resources where's the
new money to make this work well
actually the spending review we secured
extra money for the minister of justice
i've got uh 12 real term uh increase the
largest for a decade that means that we
can fund um and the age the attorney is
responsible for the cps but we can fund
the prosecutions and in particular in my
area the independent sexual violence
advisers that support victims through
because we know victims just say they
don't want to go through with a trial
not only is that terrible denial of
justice for them but we don't get the
prosecutions and bang up the people lock
up the people that are responsible i
think there's also something i mean you
touched on it there's a little bit of
finger pointing that goes on in the
system you have operational independence
for the police the cps of course for the
judiciary one of the things that we've
been trialling and rolling out is what's
called operation soteria which means
that the prosecutors and the police look
when they get a case not just constantly
scrutinizing the victim if they
made inconsistencies what they said but
the rigor goes on scrutinizing what the
suspect has done and what the suspect
has said that along with the other
measures is helping to drive up
confidence in the system and again we
want to roll that out nationally too
over time the low conviction rate does
not inspire confidence in women we know
that and one other thing that
we know is a problem
is that women are reluctant to come
forward and report rape or sexual
assault because they do not have
confidence in the way they will be
treated by the police we only have to
say the words
sarah everard yeah to uh
to explain what that means what what
what are you doing to restore that
confidence so there's a whole range of
things that we'll announce this week but
let me just give you a flavour so first
of all these criminal justice scorecards
which will be for generic crime but also
for rape particularly and in the new
year we'll make them break them down for
localized areas we'll show not just
victims but the whole of a community the
the public where we're getting it right
where we're getting it wrong
i think that's important i'm also going
to be announcing this week a
consultation on a victim's law which
will put victims in relation to rape and
sexual violence but also across the
board at the center of what the criminal
justice process does i think morally
that's the right thing to do i think
justice is there for the victims i think
also frankly from an operational point
of view making sure victims have got
confidence in the system hang on through
not just to report it to the police
we've actually seen an increase in
reporting to the police but are willing
then to go
willing then to go to trial that is the
way we give them the confidence but we
also frankly from a data point of view
from a results point of view drive up
the number of convictions but the issue
here is police behavior what are you and
your colleague over homo for saying to
the police about the way they
behave well in the aftermath of sarah
everard and
the issue around wayne's wayne cousins
there are all sorts of views that have
been put in place to see
both in relation to whether the warning
signs should have been heeded earlier
about wayne cousins but also things like
systematic practice cultural points uh
about whether
we are dealing whether sexism frankly is
being dealt with properly in the police
and so so those things are being dealt
with i think this issue of the
cooperation the coordination the
collaboration between prosecutors and
the police though is absolutely critical
we respect the operational independence
of both but operation section shows you
how a more collaborative approach more
transparency frankly a little bit more
evaluation assessment of what's going on
seeing the breakdown where those
countries where those uh
local police forces and prosecuted
prosecutorial teams are innovating and
driving up results we want to say if you
can do it there why not spread that best
practice across the country i think
that's what gives victims hope okay i
just don't need to i mean this is a
politics program so let me just ask you
one question about politics you
you won in bexley uh but actually part
of the reason that um
you didn't do as bad as you might have
done is or that you did do uh as badly
as you did rather is that um
nigel farage's party reform party took
um seven percent of the votes they kept
their
they kept their deposit um are you
worried about the return of farage
look we worry about delivering for the
people of this country whether it's on
vaccines economy criminal justice but
that would you say well bexlin sid cup
um for a government two years in we took
over half of that is the question i
asked you asked about nigel farage i'm
worried about neither
foreign government particularly as the
conservatives we should be focusing on
the people's priorities which is not
worrying about the political competition
it's worrying about delivering for the
people of this country in bakersfield
syd cup we secured in again two years in
for a government from the last election
time where uh historically we come under
a lot of pressure uh at by-elections we
secured uh over half the vote with this
great candidate louis french who i will
campaign with and we're going to
continue focusing on the people's
priorities